Ares Sullivan is naturally a homeless
person Cox met on a trip to Las Vegas
that's true
Gary Haven was you know a $20 male
prostitute out and told him I was doing
a survey for the Salvation Army paid 20
bucks could he enter 17 if you want the
long version of this story as long as
first layer the first podcast yeah you
only did with Matt you ought to put the
man [ __ ] you ought to put the little the
little things like when their watch like
watch it you should do that throughout
the whole thing like watch the whole
yeah oh yeah obviously people if you
haven't already watched the first
podcast with Matt that is the zinger
that's the one that has like one and a
half million views yeah yeah Pharoah
it's cold it was like number 50 no it's
like 40 some was it really that's 43 or
something and you know the thing in and
look hey here's the thing - and that
podcast is maybe 50% of the story I mean
the whole story I write the whole
[ __ ] story so you really know how how
I did this what I did that the whole
thing oh it's number forty number forty
podcast number four you was the first
one we did that's where you told all of
the story about Las Vegas were like were
like 50 sick are you
you're buying it you're buying me dinner
you gotta buy me what are you talking
about a virus going on around here I'm
not getting [ __ ] Kovac did you know
that they canceled [ __ ] two James
Bond movie tomorrow no James Bond
canceling movies the movie theater I
love James Bond everything's [ __ ]
canceled man that's crazy it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous the NBA's
canceled they canceled all the NBA games
I've broken up about that I don't watch
sports so yeah anyways that's pretty
big-time acting [ __ ] Diaz a lot of
money in the NBA
yeah well I'm starving
by the way yeah anyway questions he said
no problem
this is a scam Cox does again and again
he would take this form that he created
they titled a Federal Statistical survey
tried to make it look from you know
official form number in the small print
it has u.s. government printer office
I need ask for you know full name at
birth you know the their mother's maiden
name father's name
security had they ever been arrested any
kind of information that could have felt
when I was being when I was being
interviewed by her and then the US
Attorney they asked me where I got the
form and I what do you mean they go well
this is a government form where'd you
get it and I went did you download it
and I went that's not a government for
they go it says it's a government form
right here like they're like angry every
time I ever said anything that was true
that they disagree what they get angry
Wow this it says it right here is like
no that's not I made the form I got the
[ __ ] look I got the logo here I got
that and they were always like they
really I wasn't you know so shocked I
was just like but what by the time
you're done with the interview you
realize you just don't know anything
yeah I thought I really thought I was
gonna walk in and they had all laid out
and they knew everything but they really
don't they they know bits and pieces
mm-hmm so but yet the the the form was
completely fabricated yeah he gives the
conman everything he needs to create a
new identity
I ordered a social security card I
ordered everything
with his identity secured as Gary
Sullivan Cox learns about the Browns
home and moves in for the kill he was
very unassuming very demure kind of
quiet
the conman cracks jokes at his own
expense he talks about the braces he
just had put on his loins and he said
when you're as short as I am you don't
have much to go it so everything has to
be perfect
the conman is so good Bridget Brown
feels sorry for it and we knew from what
we were told that he had a bad credit
history so I was concerned that you know
he may be in County
going into that situation again yet I
wasn't thinking that this was a criminal
mastermind that was really playing us I
just thought this is a young man who's
very insecure and trying hard here even
now I get upset for the fact that these
people have worked all their lives and
we come in and just you know with the
and they want to believe you everybody
wants to believe someone they don't want
them to think that you know you're gonna
cheat them out of their you know their
life savings or whatever and that's what
we did it's not what happened the Browns
think they've closed the book on their
housing crisis they're wrong a lender
referred for referred him to me for
closing Mary now degenhardt is a real
estate attorney in Columbia South
Carolina
a few days after representing Gary
Sullivan at another closing she talks to
an abstract ER someone who researches a
properties title she said your your
mortgage is recorded in first position
but there's four or five right behind
you within two days on the same property
I knew then what he had done he had
refinanced with several of different
attorneys and there's a lag time at
County so you would have never seen the
mortgage until they hit all at once
it's too late the mortgage checks you
asleep how many times how many people in
the guys in the comment section let's
say like that's not possible
you can't do that the banks that well
that's a title that's a title person
right there just told you that that's
very possible
Matt Cox has taken 1.2 million dollars
on a $200,000 house 1.2 houses that
their house and another house their
house I didn't get 1.2 I got like 400
I got like 900,000 or something like on
theirs and I got like 400,000 another
because the total was like 1.3 million
right but it was two different houses
okay it's just one of those things like
they decided they they must have said
although for [ __ ] at it - yeah - that
will just add it to a little stretch
that true to complicate a little bit
which is fine still more attaining
that's fine the banks in town
immediately I believe what Kobe was the
one that put a fraud alert out through
the system it was bad
on March 4th 2005 very Sullivan strolls
into a Wachovia Bank in Columbia South
Carolina to withdraw money the bank
teller sees that a fraud alert has been
issued on this name within I thought you
had plastic surgery John at this point
no no I hadn't done the hair the hair
yet but you had the nose job no no no I
hadn't had it done yet oh okay I thought
you did minutes deputy sheriff's arrived
and asked Gary Sullivan to come downtown
I had the nose don't freak it out and
he's arguing with the guy from Wachovia
and we're arguing yeah I had it done by
I convinced for the hair thing illegal
about taking out multiple loans from the
same house
up now I remember this story from
podcast number four yeah yeah yeah from
fried cast number forty also a book also
in the book you got to buy the book and
Matt Cox talked his way out this time
for more information and web exclusives
on the crimes of Matt Cox go to American
grieved on cnbc.com acts that go to
inside true crime calm
[Laughter]